Speaker 1: Today. We're going to start with
two different interviews. It's a tale of two
interviews with liar Congressman elect George
Santos, a Republican. In the first interview,
we are going to see Jorge Santos interviewed by
a woman named Skye, a striker from the Political
Personalities with Skye program. This seems
to be almost like a friend of his. In fact,
it seems maybe they do know each other from
watching the interview. Friendliest interview
in the world. And yet it still is a disaster based
on the continued lies that Santos tells. Later,
we will look at now Fox News correspondent or
contributor Tulsi Gabbard interviewing George
Sanders. And you know what? That was his credit.
She does a good job of calling out his lies.
So let's jump right into it as a reminder for
context. This is George Santos, who won a seat at
the U.S. House of Representatives as a Republican.
He basically made up his entire life's history. He
lied about his work history. He lied about his
educational history. He lied about being Jewish.
He said he's gay. And it does appear that that's
actually that part is actually true. But he's in
some cases calling these merely embellishments. In
other cases saying, well, I never really committed
a crime and in other cases sort of doubling down,
in fact, on some of the lies. So this that you are
going to see, this is an insult to journalism.
This is one of the most absurd parodies of
journalism that I've ever seen. Sky Striker First
question What made you feel like you needed to lie
about your resume? Gets interesting quick.
Speaker 2: What caused you to even feel the
need to exaggerate who you are on paper?
Speaker 3: Started this slate. Look,
I didn't outright lie about my heated experience.
Actually, I'm fairly well-rounded in the
financial markets and capital markets right now.
Speaker 1: Whether you're well-rounded or not. You
literally said you worked at places you didn't.
Speaker 3: Work for a very long time,
but I'll take you back to the beginning. So
I worked as a customer service agent for six,
seven months of my life or so eight maybe in some
at some point in 2011, 2012. Okay. And, you know,
I'm not ashamed of it, Sky, but the moment I put
that on a resumé and I put it out there elitist,
like The New York Times like to call
blue collar jobs like that. Odd jobs.
Speaker 1: Guys, you see what's going on here?
It's because of the elitist woke New York Times
that wouldn't have taken his customer service
experience seriously, that he essentially had
no choice but to claim to work for Goldman Sachs
or wherever it was. It's because of the woke
New York Times that he had to do it. He didn't
really have a choice. They forced him into it.
Speaker 3: Because, you know, it just
doesn't fit their bourgeoisie style
lifestyle. Right. So that bougie.
Speaker 1: Left media made me
have to lie about my experience.
Speaker 3: It's those expectations
and those negative connotations from elitist
organizations such as The New York Times that
lead people like me, who I'm very comfortable in
saying I come from poverty, I come from a family
of absolute nothing. And I worked really hard
to get where I am today. And the reality is, is,
yes, I committed like past employment history that
was irrelevant to the role, although one can argue
customer service is pretty important for me.
Speaker 1: But he also made up
employment history that didn't.
Speaker 3: Exist out of Congress. But I guess
they just don't see it that way. And and, you
know, for for a poor use of words, maybe. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Poor. You thought this guy made it
up whole cloth. And he's essentially saying they
made me do it. They just have these expectations.
It's everybody else's fault that I that I had to
make it up, which I kind of didn't. Then he
explains why he was married to a woman. Now
this I actually don't find this to really be
a super interesting part of the story because
because of social pressures and stigma and a lot
of different reasons, it's not that rare that gay
men at some point have relationships with women
or might even be married to women. It's it is
interesting to hear him explain it, though.
Speaker 3: Now, the one thing I will say is
I'm sorry for having had a life, for having had
a complicated life. Oh, maybe I'm married. Yeah,
I did marry young, and I married a young
woman at the time, and we pretty much were
in love and then we weren't. Because that's why
I decided after a long time, like many who don't,
to come out and say I'm gay, but I'm not
going to lead you along and this is toxic
and this relationship isn't going to work.
And I set myself free and I set her free.
Speaker 1: I think this is completely
fine. I don't think this is a big deal
whatsoever. Then they go into, what about
your constituents? What are your constituents
thinking about all of this dishonesty?
Speaker 2: So, George, how do you think
your constituents are feeling right now?
Speaker 3: I can't answer that because I
don't. No. I have people who have reached out
to me and given me the utmost support. They have
people who have reached out to me, frustrated with
the reports and wanting to know more. And I have
been giving the same explanation to people one off
for the last couple of days. I was silent to the
media because I don't dance to the tune of the New
York Times. Right. Whichever or MSNBC or whoever
I danced to the tunes of my constituents. So I
have been very heavily, intensively on the phone
talking to them, calling them, making sure people.
Speaker 1: He's been have. By the way, this guy
just makes up words heavily incentive, Lee.
Yesterday he made up the word in grand G-8 and
the phrase the NIT and gritty as opposed to
the nitty gritty. He's constantly making up
words. It's sort of like an interesting aside.
Speaker 3: Who volunteered for and it's been an
overwhelming response of George we'll have to
do to get a job done. We didn't care what your
resume might look like, quite frankly.
Speaker 1: If they didn't care,
then why did you lie? Of course, is the question.
Well, because The New York Times made him one
question has been, will he resign? Increasing
pressure on him to resign. This interview was
from two days ago. At this point, he makes it
very clear he's not going to resign. However,
maybe he will because things have changed since.
Speaker 3: Get stuff done. I will be an effective
member of Congress. I will be a diligent
member of Congress, and I will be able to
deliver results for Congress, for the people
of New York's third district, because I'm not
going to allow this to deter me from doing that.
Speaker 1: Right. So making it clear he's not
going to resign. However, the pressure continues
mounting and maybe he will end up resigning. Now,
here was an interesting question and
you'll find out why it's interesting
very quickly. He has made claims about
property ownership. In this interview,
he's asked by Sky are striker playing the role
of a of an interviewer in this video about the
property stuff. Take a listen to what he says.
Speaker 2: Okay. I mean, that's a good attitude to
have. I have a few other questions that maybe we
can address really quick about property that you
owned. George, do you own property? Do you not?
Speaker 3: So George Santos I mean, personally,
I've never claim to own property myself.
Speaker 1: I have never claimed to own
property myself. Okay, that's pretty clear.
Speaker 3: No, no, I do not own property. I've
I've never purchased property under my name.
Speaker 2: I've thought about your
family property.
Speaker 3: I think that only has
property and I'm able to use of their property and
I help them out with, you know, keeping the books
and stuff like that. But that's a family affair.
Speaker 1: Okay. So no property doesn't have
property. Never claim to own property. Here he is
saying he's sold the property. Okay, let's see if
I've got this line up. Right. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 3: Think that's funny? I two years ago,
I sold a property. I had 28,000.
Speaker 1: I sold a property. I had
not I helped my family sell a property
of theirs. I sold a property I had.
Speaker 3: Sold 22 years ago. I sold a property
I had up 28th Avenue all the way down by the
water by just go straight. Right. Because the
shelter went up on 20th Avenue and it was very
controversial and I sold the property there. But
what I can tell you is that that area should have
never been built on. That is a swamp that used
to be the Flushing Airport and the swamp took
over and then they insisted on building up
an academy there. You know, it's a beautiful
building. I think it's a gorgeous project. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I've never claimed to own a property.
Oh, I sold a property I had because I didn't like
the fact that a shelter went up. Doesn't really
sound like you're saying it's a family property,
does it? So just it's lie on top of lie on top of
lie. Then we get to the issue of his false claims
that he's Jewish. Okay. Let's listen to that.
Speaker 2: Right. And the controversy about your
ancestors in the Holocaust. How did that how did
that become such a story in these different
Jewish publications, whether they were in the
Holocaust or they weren't in the Holocaust? And do
I wish you a happy Hanukkah or a merry Christmas?
Speaker 3: So, as I've said many times, and I
think you've heard me say this, I always joke
I'm Catholic, but I'm also Jew ish, and then.
Speaker 1: You guys can tell he's Jew.
Speaker 3: Ish. And I've made that joke because
growing up, I grew up fully aware that my
grandparents were Jewish, came from from a Jewish
family, and they were refugees to Brazil. And that
was always the story I grew up with, and I've
always known it very well, and I've told it the
way it was told to me. Now, if, if it just strikes
me so odd, people are rushing to this inherent
mean from being Jewish or for even allowing to.
Speaker 1: He's there's no evidence that
those stories are.
Speaker 3: True care
for Israel and Judaism in a time and an air.
Speaker 1: Guy is he likes Israel why can't we
just call him Jewish. I mean if after after all
that, why can't we just allow him to do it? Now,
of course, Rolling Stone report, Jorge Santos, who
said he never claimed to be Jewish, once called
himself a, quote, Proud American Jew. Proud
American Jew. I never claim to be Jewish. No,
I never claimed that. Okay. And then one more
video here. What does Jorge say to people who
now worry they won't be able to trust him?
Speaker 2: But are there people? I'm sure
there are. What do you say to them that
are going to hold this against you and
say that they can't trust you because
of these exaggerations that you've made.
Speaker 1: Exaggerations.
Speaker 3: You were able to trust? Worse, they
were able to trust Andrew Cuomo to harass women.
Speaker 1: His argument is they've
trusted worse people than me.
Speaker 3: His entire career.
They were able to trust his James, who harbored a
sexual predator as her chief of staff. Right. They
were able to trust all litany of politicians
in this country who have literally sold this
country out. Look at the president of the
United States. So guess what? I will make
them trust me by delivering results. I'm not
here for self-empowerment, self and grandeur.
I'm just here to get stuff done because I want to
leave our country better off to the next. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I guess you should trust
him. Because worse people have held
office. A humiliating attempt in an interview
by Sky Striker. And just lies upon lies. The
dishonesty is just seeping through. This
guy's every pore and orifice of his body.
Horrifying. A horrible liar. And fortunately,
Tulsi Gabbard actually took him to task.